Air Force Academy Lieutenant General J
Silverio
[Applause]
you
you
[Applause]
wing present arms
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States Donald J Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
wing order arms
you
[Music]
you
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
graduating class of 2019
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
graduates Holt left hey wing present
arms please remain standing for the
playing of the national anthem and the
invocation
[Music]
wing order ours at ease ladies and
gentlemen chaplain Colonel Paul D Souter
United States Air Force Academy and
command chaplain please join me in
prayer according to your practice or
tradition gracious god what a fantastic
day to fly and an even more glorious day
to graduate you O Lord have created the
land sea sky and beyond you formed all
people in your image we thank you for
the rich diversity of the 61st
graduating class of the United States
Air Force Academy our cadets represent
all the states and territories of
America as well as our Allied nations
from around the world may their example
of solidarity and perseverance through
the challenges of their Academy
experience remind us all of the rich
rewards gained from loving our neighbors
near and far and encourage us to afford
dignity and respect to all we are proud
of our rich military heritage and the
heroes and heroines who have led the way
the Neil Armstrong class of 2019 has
lived up to their exemplar as well as
the gold standard of their class colored
and the challenge of their motto conquer
mind conquer all we give thanks for all
who have supported their accomplishments
family friends benefactors Academy staff
faculty professors Supervisors in peers
bless and give them your love mercy and
wisdom always we are especially grateful
to the members of the legacy class of
1969 in the many sponsors who inspired
our cadets along the way this day
culminates a well-deserved return
extraordinary efforts expended
individual goals have been exceeded in
the future of the long blue line blazes
bright because these graduates have done
and given their best bless the leaders
of our land that we may be people at
peace among ourselves and a blessing to
other nations of the earth bless
especially our keynote speaker and the
president of these are United States
President Donald Trump that his words
would motivate us to renewed commitment
to our country as well as our neighbors
around the globe as our graduates pin on
the rank of second lieutenant and go off
into the wild blue yonder we are mindful
that hardship and sacrifice will remain
their constant shadow in the words of
the cadet prayer make them effective
instruments of your peace in the defense
of the skies that canopy free nations
and finally Oh Lord embolden our
graduates in us always in the pursuit of
freedom and justice from which there can
be no graduation these and all things we
asked in your Holy Name all men
graduates take seats ladies and
gentlemen
please be seated wing take seats ladies
and gentlemen
Lieutenant General J Silverio the
superintendent of the United States Air
Force Academy Wow
did Colorado come through with a
wonderful day or what good morning and
what a great day for the Air Force
Academy a great day for the Air Force
and a great day for our nation welcome
ladies and gentlemen and distinguished
guests but for the family and friends
and the graduates seated in front of me
it is especially great to say welcome to
the graduation for the class of 2019 to
explain for our guests today each
graduating class or our Academy selects
an exemplar in order to honor and
identify with a hero whose qualities
they hope to emulate in their own
careers this year's graduating costs
chose Neil Armstrong an American icon
who perhaps needs no introduction but
whose incredible accomplishments were
matched only by his admirable humility
aside from being the first person to
step on the moon Neil Armstrong was a
naval aviator a Korean War veteran a
test pilot in an aerospace engineer his
achievements are an example to our
cadets of the limitless potential of
human innovation and the strength of the
American spirit and we are proud to
honor his legacy of courage and
excellence so today whenever you here
class of 2019 the members will respond
with just what you heard strong today
we're honored to be joined by remarkable
list of distinguished guests seated
behind me and through
Falcon Stadium that the 45th President
of the United States President Donald J
Trump is joining us today
[Applause]
that he is here today as our
commencement speaker is an incredible
honor for our Academy and our graduates
and reflects the vision of our founders
that they had more than six decades and
more than 50 thousand graduates ago that
this institution would be an asset of
national importance an indispensable
value to the strength of our military
mr. president thank you for joining us
today and welcome to the United States
Air Force Academy
today we are also honored by the
presence of our 24 secretary of the air
force the Honorable dr. Heather Wilson
you saw a class of 1982 our 21st chief
of staff of the Air Force General David
L golfing you saw a class of 1983 and
our 18th Chief Master Sergeant of the
Air Force Chief Master Sergeant Khalif
oh right
seated behind me today are members of
Cadet Squadron 7 this year's outstanding
Cadet Squadron the distinction of top
squadron is awarded each year to the
squadron that achieved excellence and
superior performance in all areas of
study including academics military
training and athletics congratulations
and well done shadow 7 but also seated
behind me as a representation of our
Academy's leadership an outstanding team
of individuals who have played vital
roles in the leadership development of
this class our vice-superintendent our
director of staff our command Chief
Master Sergeant the headquarter staff
the Dean of Faculty our vice commandant
of cadets the director of athletics the
10th Air Base Wing Commander the Asafa
preparatory school commander the 306
Flying Training Group commander the
director of our Center for character and
leadership development we also have our
4 academic division chairs are for cadet
Wing a OCS we could not do what we do
without you thank you very much
and seated on the platform with us
representing the indispensable roles
that our family members play in the
lives of our cadets and airmen is my
wife Virginia and our Academy senior
leaders their spouses we will never be
able to thank you enough for your
steadfast support and for the unique
sacrifices you make as military families
I'd also like to recognize an incredible
faculty and staff who arrived in our
professional that are seated on the
south side of the stadium these
dedicated and tireless professionals
make days like today possible with their
passion for education and discovery and
with their skill in developing some of
our nation's most promising young people
into the next generation of innovation
innovative minded leaders we are truly
privileged to have such a talented
faculty and staff ensuring that officers
we are educating training and inspiring
here now will go out into our air force
and make it their own shape it into a
more capable and powerful force thank
you all for what you do to make this
happen the United States Air Force
Academy could not accomplish its mission
without the unwavering dedication of
many partners and the support of the
wonderful Colorado Springs and Front
Range region is vital to that support
seated on the north side of the stadium
are some of our most outstanding
supporters representatives from our
supporting organizations such as the
association of graduates the Asafa
endowment the fact the falcon foundation
the Air Force Academy Foundation Friends
of the Air Force Academy library the Air
Force Academy athletic corporation and
the Academy research and development
Institute let me all add let me also add
a special welcome to one of our greatest
supporters mayor Suthers thank you for
being here
also joining us are commanders from
around our joint force including
generals heighten general O'Shaughnessy
and general raymond along with our many
other distinguished guests Academy
Alumni community leaders and Friends of
the Academy thank you all for your
contributions that helped make today
possible thank you and to everyone here
supporting these young leaders this
morning know that you that we are a much
stronger force because of your
indispensible role in our Air Force
family everyone in attendance today
represents the years of development
encouragement coaching teaching
correcting supporting and loving this
class to get them here today thank you
for coming we're honored that you've
joined us to recognize the culmination
of one formative journey and the
beginning of another
today 991 exceptional young leaders of
the 61st graduating class of the United
States Air Force Academy start their
careers as officers and I am confident
that tomorrow our Air Force will be a
stronger force because of them
they are joining a long blue line and
they are joining a heritage of military
service and none other represents that
more then cadet Joseph o'clock soon to
be second lieutenant Joseph o'clock he
was commissioned yesterday by Maj Walter
clock his grandfather who's a hundred
and one years old a World War two
veteran and he is seated in Section L 8
here this morning
major clock we are honored by your
presence
ladies and gentlemen at his Mountain I
distinct pleasure to introduce the 21st
chief of staff of the Air Force general
David Algol Fein is a 1983 Yousaf a
graduate the sixth Yousefi graduate to
serve as chief of staff of the Air Force
an incredible distinguished career has
demonstrated the qualities of leadership
we'd be proud for all of our newest
graduates here to emulate general
Goldfein is a command pilot with more
than 4200 hours in aircraft including
the f-16 and the f-117 and he has led
Airmen and joint warriors in crucial
missions all over the world sir thank
you for the example you've set in your
career of selfless service and for
inspiring these graduates to see what is
possible in this proud profession and
for your enduring dedication to the alma
mater our entire Academy is proud to
welcome you back as always ladies and
gentlemen please welcome not just the
chief of staff but one of the best
friends of the Air Force Academy chief
of staff of the Air Force general David
L golfy and wait a long time to do that
well you made it I'm speaking of course
to your parents well done moms and dads
so class of 2019 let me take you back
four years ago to the 26th of June 2015
the day after you arrived here in your
first formation in front of the class
wall for the very first time as a class
you stood side by side and shoulder to
shoulder in your crisp new uniforms and
took a solemn oath
the same oath you took yesterday in your
commissioning ceremonies to support and
defend the Constitution of the United
States against all enemies foreign and
domestic
standing together as wingmen you
committed to bear true faith and
allegiance to the same
and today you stand here together
for the last time as the formation four
years later or maybe five or six for a
few of you trust me I can relate and you
join the over 50,000 graduates who have
gone before you the long blue line today
you enter an air force engaged in active
combat operations in faraway places like
Afghanistan and Syria as we deliver
global vigilance and global reach and
global power for America and like your
legacy class of 1969 several of whom are
here today many of you will face the
ultimate test in combat as together we
defend this great experiment called
democracy and as officers you will be
entrusted with the greatest treasure in
our nation's arsenal young Airmen who
volunteered to serve a nation at war and
who deserved to be led and inspired by
leaders of character
sacred duty and what you've been
preparing for since the day you first
raised your right hand in front of the
class wall
as your chief I could not be prouder to
welcome each of you into our ranks
ladies and gentlemen the long blue line
is strengthened today by the class of
2019
[Applause]
over 40 years ago dr. Heather Wilson and
I took our oath together standing in the
Fieldhouse as members of the class of
1982 like you as classmates standing
side by side and shoulder-to-shoulder
after graduation our careers took
different paths mine mostly operational
dr. Wilson took a completely different
path graduating with honors as a Rhodes
Scholar attaining her PhD in
international relations and Oxford
University she served on the National
Security Council for President George HW
Bush during the fall of the Berlin Wall
collapse of the Warsaw Pact and the
start of Operation Desert Storm she went
on to become a congresswoman from New
Mexico for 10 and a half years and a
powerful advocate for us on the hill
she's a private pilot and an aircraft
donor and become before becoming our
secretary she served as president of the
South Dakota School of Mines neither of
us could ever have imagined 40 years ago
when we took our oaths as new cadets
that would we would rejoin all these
years later to lead the institution we
loved side by side and shoulder to
shoulder mr. president on behalf of all
Airmen past present and future thank you
for nominating dr. Heather Wilson to
become the 24th Secretary of the Air
Force and recommending another
incredible and gifted leader ambassador
Barbara Barrett to become our 25th
secretary next to our commander-in-chief
today's Airmen and their families have
no better friend
and the nation has no stronger advocate
for air and space power than dr. Heather
Wilson and how appropriate that her last
official act as our secretary is here
where it all started over four decades
ago at our beloved Academy
and yet again she is graduating one year
ahead of me
graduates parents families and friends
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen it is my distinct honor and
privilege to introduce to you the 24th
Secretary of the Air Force dr. Heather
Wilson Thank You chief and thank you for
everything you have done for our Air
Force I could not have asked for a
better wingman for the parents in the
stands he is graduates are some of the
best young men and women in America
because you raised them to be that way
thank you for entrusting them to our
care know that we will give them the
training and the equipment they need to
be able to fight and win and come home
again
to our graduates in the class of 2019
there is a nation outside of this
stadium depending on you Samuel Adams
wrote in 1748 that neither the wisest
Constitution nor the wisest laws will
secure our Liberty they must be defended
by those who value freedom
you have decided to prepare yourselves
to take a solemn obligation today thank
you for choosing to be airman
41 years ago Dave Goldfein and I got
full-ride scholarships and one-way
tickets from sea level to 7258 feet far
far above Annapolis and West Point
we each got off the bus with a single
suitcase at the base of what was then
the bring me men ramp and began journeys
that have brought us back to this place
by different routes general gall free
and grew up as a joint warfighter as a
leader and I veered into public policy
in Congress and higher education in his
poem little giving TS Eliot wrote we
shall not cease from exploration and the
end of all our exploring will be to
arrive where we started and know the
place for the first time it has been my
honor to have been the first graduate of
this institution to have become the
secretary of the United States Air Force
mr. president thank you for that honor
this graduation will be my last official
event as your secretary and it has been
my honor to serve with all of you it is
also now my pleasure to introduce the
45th President of the United States
[Music]
from the day he stepped into office the
president began reversing more than a
decade of military decline
over the past three years his budget has
proposed significant increases for our
air and space forces which we have used
to restore the readiness of the force to
win any fight anytime to recruit and
train new people and to buy modern
equipment for the airmen who will be
commissioned here today
[Music]
his number-one priority has been the
safety and security of the American
people and the country that we love we
have we are privileged we are privileged
to have him here today ladies and
gentlemen the commander-in-chief and the
President of the United States Donald
Trump
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much please you just like
all those brand-new beautiful airplanes
that we're buying
[Applause]
hello Air Force Academy it's been a long
time since I've been here and what a
place what a place it is
a tease everybody I'm thrilled to be
here with all of you as we celebrate the
incredible class of 2019 and you truly
make America proud you make us all proud
thank you very much great job really
great job and I want to thank secretary
Wilson for the introduction and for her
two years of service as the first
graduate of the Academy to be the very
important secretary of the Air Force at
a time when we've really expanded out
the Air Force and bought equipment like
you've never seen before
so congratulations thank you very much a
beautiful job
and I want to thank three other truly
remarkable former cadets your
superintendent Lieutenant General J
Silverio
class of 1985 J I thought you're a
little bit younger than that General
David Goldfein class of 1983 Thank You
general
great job there's a great job respected
by everybody and NORTHCOM commander
General Terrence R Shaughnessy class of
1986 thank you very much thank you
Thank You general we're also grateful to
be joined by commander of US Strategic
Command general john heighten general
thank you very much spent a lot of time
together talking about things and
commander of Air Force Space Command
general J Raymond Thank You general
Space Command
and to all of the distinguished faculty
coaches and staff thank you for forging
and refining a new generation of
American warriors we're also joined by
many distinguished Air Force veterans
and Academy graduates we applauded
salute you all thank you very much thank
you for being here
and to the thousands of moms and dads
and grandparents and family members
beaming with joy and that's what they're
doing they are beaming with joy thank
you for raising rock-ribbed American
patriots
[Music]
America's stronger thanks to your love
and your support for these incredible
people these incredible graduates cadets
join me in paying tribute to your
amazing Air Force families go ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's beautiful
that's beautiful without them you
wouldn't be here and that's the way it
is that's the way it is most of all to
the nearly 1,000 cadets who I have
agreed to shake every single hand they
gave me a choice they said sir you don't
have to shake any hands some people do
that those are the smart ones are out of
here you can shake one hand to the one
person top of the class you could shake
ten fifty or hundred and you could also
stay for a thousand and I'm staying for
a thousand okay
and I know we're all gonna make it
there's no doubt about it
right and there's no doubt about it to
the nearly 1,000 cadets who will soon
become second lieutenants in the US Air
Force you could have chosen any school
any career you wanted but you chose a
harder path and a higher calling to
protect and defend the United States of
America I know what you've been through
and it's tougher but you know what in
the end it's better you're gonna see
you'll see you'll see today you take
your place as officers in the most
powerful Air Force in the history of our
country and frankly and very easily in
the history of the world
America commends the integrity devotion
and commitment of the class of 2019 when
you choose the airforce you choose the
noble road of service and duty and
devotion you choose to break old
boundaries and unlock new frontiers and
live life on the cutting edge the first
air combat happened just one century ago
you are the ones who will invent and
define the next generation of air
warfare and you are the ones who will
secure American victory all the time
victory to dominate the future America
must rule the skies and that is what
your time at this great Academy has been
all about preparing you to do whatever
it takes to learn to adapt and to win
win win
you know win so much you're gonna get so
tired of winning but not really
not really we'd never get tired of
winning doing no over the past four
years that's just what you've done
you've worked you've preserved
persevered you've excelled you've done
so many things that nobody else can do
and in the end you've come out on top it
took years of focus and discipline to
get here starting long before Beast
right beast you don't know what they'll
beast is right just being admitted to
the Academy is a monumental achievement
only one out of every ten applicants
makes the cut and don't forget out of
those ten applicants there are hundreds
that think about it but they know they
don't even have a chance so remember
them
it's true actually it's actually
actually true for those who are accepted
another 20% don't make it to graduation
sadly only the best survive to the very
end and here under the majestic peaks of
the Rockies you have risen to every
challenge overcome every single obstacle
and proven yourselves worthy of the bars
that will soon adorn your uniform you
survived BC team made it to recognition
and earned your prop and wings you
soared in gliders piloted aircraft and
launched satellites that are now
orbiting way way above us looking down
on us you performed advanced research
developed new tech not technically hold
your skills as cyber operators and
jumped out of planes thousands of feet
above the earth not easy for America's
Airmen the sky is never ever the limit
that being said even the best cadets can
sometimes get a little bit carried away
Lieutenant General Silve area has
informed me that a few cadets are still
on restriction for pranks and other
fairly bad mischief you know what I'm
talking about right and you all know who
you are
so keeping with tradition and as your
commander-in-chief I hereby absolve and
pardon all cadets serving restrictions
and confinements
and that you earned you earned it so
you're all on even footing is that nice
this glass has racked up a list of truly
extraordinary achievements through
graduating cadets recently received one
of the most prestigious awards in all of
academia Rhodes Scholarships please join
me in congratulating cadets James Brom
and Madison Tong please stand up
Wow
thank you very much it's a big big fat
congratulations from me that's a
tremendous tremendous job you've done
thank you
Thank You Madison great job when the
athletic fails Air Force has won 15
Conference championships over the last
four years which is really something a
hundred and fifty three athletes have
earned all-american honors stand up
stand up all-american stand up Wow
[Applause]
it's fantastic
congratulations including rifle team
members Anna wall Bakker and Spencer cap
who helped the Falcons win the air rifle
national title and beat the other
service academies to bring home the
president's trophy please stand up
it's fantastic but you didn't enjoy
beating those other academies I don't
think so right not too much and
graduating cadet Nick Reedy became the
first person from any service academy to
win the college Home Run Derby wow
that's a big deal with a record-breaking
55 home runs
Nick where are you Nick stand up get up
here Nick come here Nick
you know they gave him such a lousy seat
all the way back in the corner
come on a baseball home run derby that's
something in all of college baseball Wow
I want to feel this guy's muscles
[Applause]
it's real that's real that's great thank
you very much that's a big deal that's a
big deal the members of this class come
from every background every state the
Union and even from our allies overseas
but through trial and training and
tradition you've become one family
that's what's happened and like one
family you have all been pulling for one
of your classmates who is bravely fought
his battle with cancer
today Parker Hammond graduates as a
munitions and missiles maintenance
officer
along with the class that has stood with
him every step of the way
great goat come on Parker get up here
Parker Parker come here right come here
they love you Barker why do you like him
so much
great great
[Applause]
a lot of good-looking people in this
school I have to say thank you Parker
this class personifies the spirit of
confidence and courage and unwavering
commitment that is always defined the
long blue line it's true it goes all the
way back to the very beginning to the
first cadet in the Air Force history on
in-processing day you've greeted at the
base of a ramp by the statue of the
legendary Val bork Val grew up in a
blue-collar family in Massachusetts
during a senior year in high school he
was recruited to play for the Pittsburgh
Pirates
it's another baseball player but instead
Val made the same choice as all of you
the choice of life of service that's
what he wanted Val joined the US Air
Force Academy he showed up at 4:30 a.m.
when the Academy's opening day in 1955
so he would be the first airforce cadet
in history to take the oath of
allegiance he was thinking fast the
Academy proved an arduous challenge
however for Val
was it easy as Val's roommate said he
was hanging on by a thread academically
no one was tested more than Val was but
he was at the very top in his character
and in honor that's what his roommates
said after Val finally made it to where
you're sitting today he volunteered to
go to Vietnam and he proved to be one of
the best pilots America had he was
amazing he was incredible after nearly a
year of intense action he was scheduled
to return home he was very excited but
he asked to lead one more mission on
that day vows plane was struck by enemy
fire and he made the ultimate sacrifice
for his country he now rests on these
precious grounds and his fighting spirit
lives in each and every one of you great
fighting spirit
the heroes and legends of every
generation have always had to confront
new perils and defeat new dangers no one
can foresee all of the challenges this
class will face but we do know that with
absolute certainty you are going to be
ready to serve you are going to be ready
to lead you are going to be aiming at
the absolute highest point then you are
ready to fly fight and win always win
always you exemplify the grit the guts
and the grace that make America's Air
Force by far the best in the world and
in the words of your class motto conquer
mind conquer all each of you has the
sharp intellect deep character inner
strength and the titanium courage to
vanquish any menace that dares to
threaten our country or our people
we're always ready right general always
ready he's ready I wonder how that's
gonna be viewed that statement tomorrow
in the press you can imagine and that's
okay let them think whatever they want
to think
more than half of you will soon head to
pilot training where you'll prepare to
unleash American Thunder anywhere we
need another 45 will join our remotely
piloted aircraft program a record number
of you will become space operators you
will specialize in combat rescues
intelligence missile maintenance weather
air-traffic control engineering and much
much more each of you is graduating at a
truly incredible time for our country
our country is doing well our country is
respected again
we are respected again and we're real
wakening American pride American
confidence and American greatness you
know that these gentlemen know it I'll
tell you right now thank you very much
thank you very much that's very nice and
we're restoring the fundamental
principle that our first obligation and
highest loyalty is to the American
citizen
no longer will we sacrifice America's
interests to any foreign power we don't
do that anymore in all things in ways we
are putting America first and it's about
time
our economy is booming
our people are thriving and our military
is stronger mightier and more powerful
with all of that new aircraft than ever
before I am committed to keeping our
military the best-trained best-equipped
and most technologically advanced
fighting force anywhere Under the Sun
last year against some pretty strong
opposition which I'll always have we
secured 700 billion dollars to support
our war fighters followed by another 716
billion not million billion that's with
a B 716 billion dollars this year that
means we are delivering 56 new Air Force
f-35s brand-new stealth
[Music]
I asked somebody on the other side what
do you think of that plane a foreign
leader so we have a problem boy that we
can't see it so it's good it's always
good when they can't see you 24 new
Reaper remotely piloted aircraft 15 new
Pegasus aerial refueling aircraft 10 new
combat rescue helicopters and a
well-earned pay raise for every soldier
sailor Airman Coast Guardsman and marine
in the United States military
and if anybody wants to give up your
raise it's okay we'll accept that okay
don't do it
we're also asking Congress to invest
more in hypersonic weapons we have
things under development the likes of
which you've never seen the likes of
which you can't even conceive artificial
intelligence nuclear weapons and
modernization and space superiority and
we're soon having as you know something
that I started and it started a little
slow and now everybody's embraced it
space force and you're gonna be working
in general I want to thank you for
helping us so much it's been really
great working with you has been great
old new force in this stadium today are
many of the future leaders who will
develop the doctrine strategy and
technology to restore America's legacy
of leadership in space as you know other
nations are moving aggressively to
weaponize space with new technologies
that can disrupt vital communications
and blind satellites that are critical
to our battlefield operations it is a
time for America to reclaim the ultimate
high ground and prepare our young
warriors for today for victory on the
battlefield tomorrow it's a very
different battlefield it's a very
different type of warfare but we are so
advanced and when you see what's coming
you won't even believe it and hopefully
you know what hopefully we never have to
use it peace through strength peace
through strength
as your commander-in-chief I want you to
know that we will pursue and maintain
the overwhelming strength we need to
deter any aggressive and thrash any foe
for that reason I am committed to
building the air force we need with the
full strength of three hundred and
eighty six squadrons and we're getting
it done - it's happening rapidly because
nothing will ever strike more fear in
the hearts of our enemies or inspire
more confidence in our friends than the
roaring engines of American fighter jets
flown by the greatest pilots on the
planet Earth by far you
the sound of American war pace is the
righteous sound of American justice
today you inherit a legacy of service
and valor handed down through
generations it's a tradition built by
legends like Rickenbacker Doolittle's
wagon Archer Boyd Jager sergeant
Grissom and Chapman great people great
people these Trailblazers broke barriers
after barrier and they innovated and
adopted to push America further faster
and onto total victory it is the same
spirit embodied by your class exemplar
Neil Armstrong who started out flying
jets over Korea and 50 years ago this
summer planted our great American flag
on the face of the moon just like all of
the Aces of our past and the heroes of
our history they were ready to lead when
America needed them most and so as every
cadet who graduates today is that
correct I think so
you are the Patriots whose names will go
down in Air Force history you will
redefine warfare at a very very critical
time in our country's history you'll win
great battles and bring our enemies to
crushing defeat you will explore the
boundaries of space and keep America
forever proud and forever free so today
you take the controls you're going to
push it up and chart your course across
the sky keep the wings level and true
because your country is sending you on a
vital mission to defend America protect
our people and to pursue our nation's
great and glorious destiny nothing will
stop you from victory nothing will
the US air force and with your help
nothing ever ever will stop the United
States of America
so I want to conclude by giving a very
special congratulations to a very
special group of amazing cadets and
people it's the class of 2019 on behalf
of our nation god bless you god bless
the Air Force and god Bless America this
is a great honor being with you thank
you and congratulations double-bubble
thank you
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the cadet class
president for 2019 get at first class
Jacob c-suite oh the summer cadet wing
commando cadet first class Madison fro
be the fall cadet Wing Commander cadet
first class Matthew Mawlid and the
spring cadet Wing Commander cadet first
class
Erica Barnett will present the class
gift to the president
president Donald Trump if your dedicated
service to our nation to the United
States Air Force and say United States
Air Force Academy it is with great pride
that today's graduating class designates
you by acclamation an honorary member of
the United States Air Force Academy
class of 2019
[Applause]
as tangible evidence of that honor we
ask that you accept this painting by
Rick Broome on behalf of the United
States Air Force Academy we also present
you with our class coin as a token of
our appreciation
[Applause]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen mr. David Pollan
char president of the Air Force Academy
Foundation will present the
distinguished American award mr.
president on behalf of the Air Force
Academy Foundation and all the
charitable organizations that support
the Air Force Academy I am pleased to
present to you the distinguished
American award thank you for being here
today to recognize and honor the next
generation of American heroes their
families and friends
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen take seats ladies
and gentlemen
Brigadier General Andrew Armacost the
dean of faculty President Trump before
presenting the entire graduating class
to you I would like to single out some
individuals for special recognition
first I call to your attention
102 distinguished graduates who are
listed at the top of your program these
cadets by their overall performance have
placed in the top 10 percent of their
class and have demonstrated true
excellence in accomplishing the academic
military and athletic requirements for
graduation if we observe the custom of
academic honors each would be graduating
either summa [ __ ] laude magna [ __ ] laude
or [ __ ] laude instead we use the term
distinguished graduate as most fitting
in its promise of distinguished service
to our nation at this time will the
distinguished graduates of the Neil
Armstrong class please rise and be
recognized
great thank you please be seated
those identified in your program with an
S beside their name are cadets
graduating with the Academy Scholar
distinction having completed
successfully a challenging academic
enrichment path through the four-year
core curriculum we would also like to
recognize those cadets who have placed
in the top 10% of our academic military
and athletic programs identified in your
program with a star by their name our
cadets graduating with academic
distinction those identified in the
program with a wreath beside their names
are cadets graduating with military
distinction those identified in the
program with a lightning bolt beside
their names are cadets graduating with
athletic distinction and those
exceptional 9 cadets graduating with all
three distinctions are identified in the
program with a star within a wreath
resting on two lightning bolts please
stand as I call your names tray
Landon Arnold Kyle Andrew Leland
Kyle David hake Molly Catherine Olmos
[Applause]
Nikolas been Hurley Ryan Christopher
Palmer grace Lynn char Lanza Pierce
Thomas Cass Mayer and finally Ryan
Joseph Howell
[Applause]
congratulations Saul please have a seat
we are also pleased to have in the class
graduates from ten foreign nations they
will stand as I recognize their Nations
we have students representing the
nations of Kazakhstan
[Applause]
the Republic of Korea
[Applause]
Romania
[Applause]
Rwanda sri lanka
Taiwan Thailand
the Philippines
[Applause]
Singapore and finally Tunisia and for
one last photo a poll all of our
international students please stand and
be recognized one more time
[Applause]
thank you please be seated
in conclusion a total of nine hundred
and ninety-one Air Force Academy cadets
in this year's class have completed all
graduation requirements it gives me
great pleasure to present to you
president Trump the United States Air
Force Academy Neil Armstrong class of
2019 and I recommend each as worthy of
the Bachelor of Science degree ladies
and gentlemen
Colonel Arthur W premise junior director
of admissions and dr. Tom Mabry
associate dean for student academic
affairs an Academy Registrar will now
present the diplomas to the graduating
class of 2019
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Donald J Trump
president of the United States joins us
on stage to congratulate each of the
graduates of the class of 2019
well the distinguished graduates please
rise and come forward to receive your
diplomas
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
okay right the class of 2019
number one cadet in overall performance
Trey Landon Arnold the class of 2019
number one cadet in academic performance
Kyle Andrew Leland come on Kyle
David Haig erika storm Barnett Samantha
Livingston Cole's Potter Molly Catherine
Houmas Georgia Ellison Sims Brian
William Ram signer Hilary Ellen Keeley
[Music]
Lucas Brian B's nur
Nicholas been early Ryan Christopher
Palmer grace Lynn Sherr Lanza
Christopher Philip Clark Cathryn Sophia
Malone the class of 2019 s number one
cadet in military performance Jenna sue
John's peers Thomas Cass Meyer Matthew
Alexander mal wig James Walter Brahm
Brian Thomas Olsen Christopher Michael
volts Joshua Joseph cows Ryan Joseph how
[Music]
Madison Li Tong Caitlyn Alexis cook
McKenzie dal Rosenthal Melanie and
Shaddix Austin Davis McDaniel
[Applause]
Benjamin Charles Jake Minh Zachary Quinn
Warren stephen daniel Steiner John
Israel Ferguson Graydon Phillip Gribble
Colin Michael zabba slack Eric Duncan
McMillan
[Music]
Jared Patrick Henderson Parker Daniel
Neal Conan Bryan malt Carly an K buds
[Music]
[Applause]
Lydia and Byram Steven Edward Beresford
John writer Jordan Adam Ray Brown Dean
forest
Ron's Minh Benjamin Edward Flanagan
Lauren Elizabeth Truex Brooke and
Konzelman Cameron Andrew Hoover Esther
so men Kim Yaroslav borrowed n carve
[Music]
Andrew Charles de Nicola Joshua William
Turner
[Music]
Gabrielle and Evie James Brewer Ayers
Emily
Claire Bertrand Christopher Robert Darcy
ty Nicholas dee dee Abraham Monroe
[Music]
Charles Parker Jack's Elizabeth Michelle
Reed Sean
Matthew ryr Garrett Franklin
Amy Richard Scott Evans Caden Richard
sparks Matthew James Cook Jordan Emma
Peterson
[Applause]
Collin William Thomas Adrienne Carol the
bush William Everett Langan coal
Matthew Shui GLE John Alexander Bose the
third Sean David Harvey
[Music]
Gabriel Scott Dolman Michael Norman
Plaza
Ronald James Jackson
Andrea Nicole able Elizabeth Stacy
Pennington Harry
Gibson McMahon the third Tamra Lee
Cardenas Andrew David Gibson mark
Frederick Mueller Nicholas Luke recei co
r is ma Jake Canyon Watkins
[Applause]
Spencer chase O'Donnell Aaron Noel
Missler Jennifer Fuu Quinn O'Shea Sylvan
cradle lien Shane Kaplan Megan Claire
Lingus Zachary Noah Wyle Austin Dixon
good Caleb
Andrew Mathis Joshua James shall awake
Elliot Owen Higgins Ellen Murray Miata
[Music]
Anthony Robert kibrit Graham dodsworth
Smith
[Music]
Kylie Murray Wharton Antonio Garza
[Music]
[Applause]
Jonathan Daniel Kaczynski
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen joining President
Trump onstage to your left
the Honorable Heather Wilson Secretary
of the Air Force and to your right
General David Goldfein chief of staff of
the Air Force also joining them on stage
to your left
Lieutenant General Jace of area
superintendent United States Air Force
Academy and on your right Colonel Scott
Campbell commander commandant of cadets
will the remainder of the graduates of
2019 please rise and come forward by
squadron to receive your diplomas
[Applause]
[Music]
Cadet Squadron one Kim Kendrick agate at
scheana Marie Arab Ito Marcus Anthony
Bennett Melissa Lee Berger beau Woodward
Billingsley Steven Gregory Carter
Michael Reese Fontenot junior Ana
Margaret Frick Riley Michael hey Ferg
[Music]
Connor James Harry Isaac Demetrio
Jimenez Saran Kathleen Marley Zephaniah
Troy Miller Andrew mo week
Nathan Richmond Sanders Jack Woodrow
smith emmy k Swezey Cheyenne kanui wall
Timothy Ryan Ward Robert John Waylan
Rowland true wheeler the fourth maverick
Allen Wilhite Geoffrey Charlton Bailey
[Music]
Cadet Squadron - Nathaniel armor vexed
Rendon Jeffrey Charlton Bailey read lei
aloha Blair Brett Michael Bixler Caston
grant Casey Julia and Elise Boswell
Jessica jr. Chan Jennifer Betsy Chan
Jacob Kelly
Priscilla Tessa Rose favo Rebecca
Madison go savage Peyton Hughes Galloway
ray Lehrer Gonzalez Seth James Hill
Michael Edward Marsh Simon Kenneth Lynn
[Music]
Jessica Nicole
Moochie Darren William Miller man you
Park Christian James Masto Catherine
Rose Tomczak Vincent
Anthony Saban Jonathan Andrew Williams
Alex say ye vows in the third Cadet
Squadron 3 Nathan Ronald a day
Marcus William brink or the class of
2019 number one cadet in athletic
performance
Sonya Danielle burns Luke William
Chapman
[Applause]
Thomas Britain Edie
the third Guinness Elise gooder Alison
Jane Goren JH Trenton Curtis Harper
Benjamin Thomas Baris page
Lynn Harrison Carson Alan Farley Kimble
Zachary Alan Lindsay shin
Chewie leo Grayson Dean mouths
Zachary Martinez Anna Kate nickel Steven
powers Parker Andrew Thomas Piper
Quincy Alexander frog Logan
Brian Skinner Charles Andrew Smith
Megan Renee van der Moss Daniel
Jordan's if Dean Cadet Squadron for
Christopher
Wesley Bowden John Thomas kanata Maria
Nicole Carter Aaron
Kathleen Cochrane Matthew Christopher
Coulter he's Sean Feli
[Music]
Devon Tyler
fino Matthew John Green
Jeremiah James Hemi Chloe Lynn Holman
[Music]
Joseph Emmanuel land close Charles
Anthony Arthur Lee ano Bradley Dillon
Martin Preston Riley Montero Racha poon
Nam luck Kelly z 'm win
Zachary David Norton Adam Christian
peltor marry Charlotte pepper
Jason Alexander Sadler Amon Patrick
Shannon
Matthew Douglas Stanley
Pablo Steven the posse ah no Cadet
Squadron five Connor
Anthony Brzezinski allonge na Toya
Brooks Zachary
Alexander carry on briefs Michael
Klingon peel Jacob Jeffrey Cole Shanley
and Conlan Michael Francis Davey Joseph
singer Ernst Tristan Leroy Hanson Hannah
James Hetzler Sean Richard jolly Sarah
Noemi cries er Blake
David Laury Christine Masako Lou
Daniel Gorman Lindauer Charles Francis
Maori the fourth Christopher Gregory
Noblin
Rodrigo Antonio Oriana Djimon Barrett
stands Caleb we stuff all Ryan
jae-hoon you Cadet Squadron six David
Norman Collins
Alexander Bryan Cologne
Brian Thomas Connelly
Christopher Oshiro doh
Chloe Antonette Gadsden Brennan Tyler
Garland
Ashley Janette got the error Samuel Rey
Hein Gardner Elizabeth marina Jarvis
Cassandra Julia McElwee Sonya Sethi
mcLaughlin
Heidi Lin Morrison Logan Wayne Ormsby
Alexa Marie Papa Romo Nikolai olkin
roads Robert John Shaffer
Zachary Adam Sokolov ski Charles IG
Treadwell Lucas Oh Finn ups
Andre Dylan bertuccio Edmund Wong Jing
Yi Cadet Squadron seven Zachary William
arns
William Jake christopoulos Noah nikana
Ella crab Lucas William Pecha berry
Jacob stickler Aaron's from Noah William
hanger Evan Richert Geisler Timothy
Cyrus hunt when asana or awawa okuni you
too boo Rachel Elaine Chester tae woo
Kim ELISA Elena
Nelson Janelle put trees parlagreco
Logan Gabriel pestle Josiah Fred Riley
Peter
Chandler washer the third Garrett
Alexander watts chance
Laurens whistle Heather Selena zimmi
Cadet Squadron 8 Quentin
Eugene Coleman
Blake Joseph daily Maria Lorraine dronin
Joshua chance from Mehta the truth Giza
Vladislav maximovich go ghoulia Jonathan
Richard Healy Nicholas Oldham Jasper
Tenzin Schwab cos and Zachary Lee
Krieger Meredith
Kimball Lasky Erin the Dre Maxwell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Anthony Jordan McLaughlin Joseph
Livingston mule jr. Patrick Isaac
O'Hanlon Kyle
Austin Ramage Megan Louise broach
Trevor Scott sinner sulky Emma
Rachelle Strom John Joseph back row the
third Min Jong Yoon
that's water 9 Francis burns Cooper the
third Dion right daaad Kirsten summer
Elliott Griffin Edward luck John Ryan
Gannon Robert Daniel Hugo Matthew gage
Kane song min-ho
Nicholas Richard learned Anna Caroline
Leland Jacob Todd maca [ __ ] Andre James
Miller
Joshua Francis mossing Charles Mackenzie
for a hug
Garrett Scott Patenaude Kevin Blake
Patterson Carl Thomas Rindell Nina Marie
Rogers Daniel Soto Junior
[Music]
Lauren Savannah Stroud James Rogers
Tatum the third Janelle Cabrera Valerio
[Music]
Cadet Squadron ten Michael Lee Bono
Isaac foster Childers Tyler Anthony the
body Thomas Andrew Cox
Isabella Vivian Farrell
Jared Darnell
flowers Emily Cheban graves Brian Noland
Guerrero Theodore stephen j-- answer
Jonathan David Colton bah Richard Alan
King the second Eric we leverets Emily
Elizabeth lures hunter angle Brett Lynn
Austin Ryan Joseph McKenna stone Eric
Miller
[Applause]
Zachary William Morris
Madeline Claire Hasan Nicholas Alexander
Pollock Devin Eric Saunders JC Raquel
Smith jessica Lee
Tobias Killian Miller Valencia Joshua
William Wilhite
that's it
ready ladies and gentlemen joining
President Trump on stage to your left
Brigadier General Andrew Armacost Dean
of the faculty and to your rights mr.
Nathan pine director of athletics Cadet
Squadron 11 Brody
Nathaniel Bagnall family and blue all
Madison Jane fro be Logan Paul
frost Michael Lawrence grey Christian
James hadn't Madeline Claire Hoff Joseph
Vicente Johnson Nicholas James us
Nicholas Allen foon drat Anna Noel
Marone ik Alexander John bossing Olivier
muta Baazi Justin Lee Nethercutt
Matthew Joseph
Falacci Darian levar Sanders Jacob
Matthew Schaeffer Colton Michael Stowe
Kendall Amelia
Thomas Andrew Philip Wis Cadet Squadron
12 Keith Bautista Brandon Edward Boone
[Applause]
Hagen Kathleen Bottomly Luke Raphael
Boyle Carter
Jean Shalaka Riley Marie Butler Clark
[Music]
Sarah
Isabella cook Avery cha Evans Bryant
Samuel Falcon ello Noah
Galen go Venice
Eric Christopher gear Darby Rose glad
Matthew Glenn Hargreaves Mason first
knocks Paul Michael Lee Nick Dowell
Lopez Shannon Elizabeth Murray Thomas
John oshika rudra meheecan Patel Brandon
Zachary rockers Anthony Francis Vacarro
Eric James yen dura John Robin DeAndre
Cadet Squadron 13 Daniel James Buddha
Lear Micah James Capra Ethan
Douglas chambers Mason James Dean
Michael Patrick Fahey briefs Michael
Fairchild Jacob read Gilbert Kayla and
Granger Renee iov new Nia opponent fall
Anneliese shigeko Howard jerod Tylor
Cruiser Griffin Thomas Lorenz Luis
Armando Martinez jr. Nicolas tie Maxie
Abigail Rose mix Mariah Ren Niehaus
[Music]
Kehinde prosper ocean Loya Christian
Michael hung Durrell Siobhan Smith Dylan
Thomas Sodor
Mary Katherine Deidre Cadet Squadron 14
Benjamin common fire John Christian
blazing game Marc Anthony Bazo Robert
William Darren bollard Spencer cap Rana
sir [ __ ] Leah chase Michael Cohen Sarah
no well Escobedo Hansen Reed Finley Ryan
Keith Gill Sydney Elizabeth hi Tom
Alexander Ivan Hess
Turner Andrew Holcomb April Suzanne hood
Emily Jean quo Matthew Scott meddler
Boston Oaks Nelson Henry correction
Hudson Henry Pierce Jenna
Michelle petty stephen daniel Plaskett
Josiah Matthew Prado Savoy Bradley Milan
Stefano [ __ ]
Donald Thomas Stutz Sierra Nicole white
Cadet Squadron 15 hub deal Jose hassanis
Rosario Luke
Robert Messier Easton Caleb O'Neill Elms
Thomas Schulte Ernst
Timothy Tanner Herman jr. jennifer lynn
Hiddink
Thomas Patrick Keith
Kathy limb Jen Liz
Maile Maldonado Mitchell McCully Gregory
jet nigh Michaela Brianne [ __ ] Joseph
heaven Redfern Brianna Rose Robertson
Dylan fanfic Tang Leo Weston tangia
Spencer Daniel Thompson
Tyler read boss
Brian J he you Cadet Squadron 16-mile Oh
Homer Browder David William Cooper
Lilian Marie Costello
Melissa Patricia de Sousa
Cody John darn old Joshua Joakim fortes
Dylan Andrew Harry
[Music]
Maxwell Richard Heath nur Jason aspirate
Hightower Jared Patrick Chester Griffin
Walter
Landrum Dylan Joel Magnus Hannah Rose
McGowan Gabrielle Marie Miller Jacob
Michael or Cassandra Eleanor Preston
Jordan Eric Rivera Carl
Isaac flutes Tyler Eric Yonkers Cadet
Squadron 17 Jamie Lagman oblong Jonah
Olsen
Angus May Aulani Kate Aloha Horicon
Garrett Ross Coulson
Brian Shane Collinsworth Maxwell James
Daniel Bailey Celeste
- Barry Blake John Gillan Lionel may uke
come already
[Music]
Robert Tanner Heckman Natalie Monique
Kettner Eric Christopher Klein Thomas
Alexander Knox del FeO Shamar Matthews
Victoria Marie Perez Nicholas Gregory
pair of ëletís Garrett William pots mile
in Flint this kwinto Brittany Christina
read Luke Dallas Sanderson Jacob Edward
secede Oh Noah Merritt wife Parker
Steven Wilson Alexander David Edward
Yantis Cadet Squadron 18 Connor Lee
brown sung-hee yoke Troy Brian Joseph
Darby
[Music]
Michaela dela Cruz to mappy Olivia
Katherine Durance John Daniel Dyckman
jr. Nathaniel Allen Enders Robert keone
got juice
Alexander Steven Boyer eagle-3 John Paul
Joyce
Anthony Jung Yong Kim Haley
Michaela lob David Paul Rosen Alan son
Luke Ariana
janae Mosley Brian Mackenzie Poythress
Kate
Ursula Randall Connor
Isaiah Rayburn James Logan Simms
Gabrielle Marie Singler
Matthew Dean stinger Charles Edward
Stevens Cadet Squadron 19 Kyle Gregory
Abraham Catherine and Anderson Matthew
Brooks Carter Alex
Richard Dan Qi William Evans devolved
the fifth Kaitlyn Elizabeth Emerson
[Applause]
Bailey Robert Landsberg Morgan Alexander
Coleman Genest
Isaac Kenneth Caston co u n-- solomon co
cachoo
dickinson lee Camille
Alexandra Leonard
[Music]
Brianna Nicole Martinez Andrew Johnson
McAdams Gabriel David Mendez
Samuel Robert rexrode Samuel Ethan san
marco lauren hunter sides
Thomas Martin stretch Logan Peter
coucher Caden Ross Taylor Michelle Leona
Thompson Hunter Austin sanu ski
Cadet Squadron 20 Louis may a Gabon John
Ericsson Alan Elizabeth Murray barnacle
David Louis Bartholomew the fourth coal
Bennett Biederman Alexander Dean Brown
Justin Riley click Austin James doing
and Marie Claire flatten Kyle Walter
Floyd Tyler why Lee Harris Dover Maxwell
James Kemper Purvis Cordell louder
Alison page Lusk Giles Richard mcgillich
Isaac Jose Perez Aaron Rachel segi see
Matthew Eugene shear James Gerard
Schwerner ELISA page Staton Nathaniel
Alexander Thomas tray Daniel
Tolleson Joshua Raymond West
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Cadet Squadron 21 Marcus Wayne Abrams
Ernest Lewis Alvino the third Jonathan
Lang Bartlett Sara Elizabeth Burton
Mafalda riche from call Isaiah Wendell
what's your junior Brianna Katherine
Chen Liam James Connelly
Charles Christian Davis
[Music]